so today I'd like to talk about how we
find disease-causing mutations this is
going to rely on a computational problem
known as read mapping and to get to that
I'd like to first talk about the the
simple fact that the cost of sequencing
a genome has decreased exponentially
over the past decade according to NIH in
2001 it cost about 100 million dollars
to sequence a human genome in 2013
that's well below $10,000 and there's a
hope that we'll soon see the $1,000
genome as genome sequencing has gotten
cheaper biologists have moved from
wanting to answer large-scale questions
about species comparison using genomes
towards using personal genomes to answer
biological questions so we moved from a
generic average-case human being to
specific humans me Pavel and Sean and we
want to say what is it that makes us
unique as humans individually so if we
look at our genomes they're largely
similar right we only have small
variations for the most part and the
most common type of mutation causing
these variations is a single nucleotide
variation so we may see a substitution
we're in the same position we might see
a C and a or a T okay so the question
then would be why do we care about this
and there's many different reasons why
we want to do personal genomics probably
the most popular one or is that they can
help us with identifying the basis of
genetic diseases
Shawn and pablum mentioned in the
assembly talk that in 2010 this child
Nicolas Volker became the first human
being to have his life saved because of
genome sequencing
they found a they were able to use gene
therapy after having performed a number
of unsuccessful surgeries and so the
hope is that this is going to be the
future of medicine that we'll be able to
identify genetic issues using an
individual genome and use these to
design effective treatments again as the
cost of sequencing a genome has
decreased we're now seeing large-scale
projects to sequence huge numbers of
genomes so in the UK there's a Personal
Genome Project with
goal that's recently launched with a
goal of sequencing a hundred thousand
human genomes of course it's not a
central focus of what we want to talk
about today we want to talk about a
computational problem today but when we
start talking about a huge number of
genomes like this there a number of
ethical issues so for example what if
you had your genome sequence and you
found out that you had a high
probability of getting some genetic
disorder later in life would your
employer be able to fire you because of
that because they wouldn't want to keep
you around and in the u.s. we actually
have had Congress pass the genetic
non-discrimination Act of 2008 which
said that employers are not able to do
this right if they find out genetic
information they're not able to prevent
you from getting health insurance or
fire you but without a good reason
so we want to move again as I said
towards a computational problem and the
computational problem is going to work
as follows once we've sequence a human
genome we can now have a reference
genome so we have a genome in a database
that we can compare against since we
know that all human genomes are very
similar so our question is how is it
that we can assemble individual genomes
now efficiently using the reference
genome information that we already have
the question would be then why don't we
use assembly right we've learned a lot
about algorithms in this course we have
a huge arsenal of different methods that
we can use to answer questions in
bioinformatics so maybe the most obvious
solution that we would do would be to
say let's just sequence let's assemble
the individual genome from scratch and
then once we have assembled that using
the assembly methods that we already
know we can compare it against the
reference genome and identify places
where the variants occur that's a
perfectly reasonable way of looking at
the problem but traditionally
constructing a de brain graph or to
assemble a genome from scratch there's
something that takes a lot of memory our
hope is that we can use the information
that's stored in the reference genome if
we have if each individual shares 99 has
99% similarity with the reference genome
then we shouldn't need to start from
scratch we should
be able to use the information that's in
that reference to help us assemble each
new individual genome so our and hope
would be maybe you could go into a
clinic and have your genome sequenced in
ten minutes using the reference that it
would collect and map your reads now
what do I mean by mapping reads by read
mapping we mean that we want to
determine where each read so each read
that's generated by the sequencing
machine has high similarity to the
reference genome
okay so rather than assembling from
scratch we're going to take each of your
sequencing reads and we're going to say
where is this read most similar to the
reference genome and does is there any
variation there so we might say we might
see a perfect substring match here we
might see a substitution here and we may
see a deletion there well we're going to
focus on a simpler question though which
is going to help us generalize the
problem which is where is it that the
sequencing reads from your genome where
is it that they match the reference
genome exactly if we can answer this
question then maybe we can generalize it
okay and so if we're given a single read
then this corresponds to a problem that
we've already seen back at the start of
the class which was the pattern matching
problem for a single pattern so you're
given a string pattern that represents a
read and then a larger string genome and
you want to figure out which positions
that pattern matches the genome as a
substring so now all we all we're doing
then is generalizing this to multiple
reads or multiple patterns we're finding
given a collection of patterns where is
it that those patterns match exactly in
the larger genome we you probably
implemented a brute-force approach to
the pattern matching problem in chapter
one if you solved the code challenge
there and probably the way that you did
it was to slide the pattern down the
genome and so if you had a pattern nanna
and you were looking in the genome
panamabananas' now we're going to use
words or things that are close to words
so we're going to use like the structure
of English so that I don't have to say
AC GTT GGG because this is a string
problem okay so we're going to assume
that our genome is panamabananas' and
this is an example that we'll come back
to and so say that we have this high
pathetical read naina if we want to find
the exact matches then we simply slide
it down we see in the first position P
and n don't match so we slide it down
and n don't match and then in the third
position we see a match of n okay and so
we say well let's move to the second
position we see two matches the third
position we don't match and so we can
slide this the pattern down to the next
position no match no match no match no
match and then we finally reach an and
again and we see that there is a pattern
match there and then we're at the end of
the string so this seems like a
perfectly reasonable approach we take
each pattern and we just slide it down
the genome and find out where the
pattern matches so I think maybe we can
call it a day early today or at least on
this problem maybe we can start
generally going ahead and generalizing
from the exact pattern matching problem
but I think we've got a perfectly
reasonable way of solving the multiple
pattern matching problem